nelson mandela tenant sa famille
ses premiers pas d'homme libre premiers
pas hésitants comme surpris de la foule
venue attendre
[Musique]
la dernière barrière franchie ses
parents sa prison du monde extérieur il
ya 15h15 à paris
l'instant historique qui met fin à 27
ans 6 mois et 6 jours de captivité pour
cet homme de 71 ans
c'est merveilleux j'en ai des frissons à
quoi
est un vrai bain de foule du symbole
vivant de la lutte anti-apartheid sans
aucune déclaration le couple mandela
prend aussitôt la route précédé d'un
immense cortège
direction l'hôtel de ville du cap parce
que jean km des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont déjà massés là attendant
les premières paroles publiques de leurs
leaders depuis trois ans la matinée
cette foule immense attend sous un
soleil de plomb la violence va
malheureusement entaché cette journée
historique
une centaine de jeunes noirs surprennent
à la police j'ai bouteille pillages de
magasins riposte des forces de l'ordre
résultat un morts une centaine de
blessés
la lutte contre l'apartheid et pour la
libération de mandela a été un déclic
pour vous oui c'est ce qui m'a fait
m'engager parce que nous étions nombreux
quand même parmi la jeunesse a refusé ce
régime raciste mais le fait qu'on soit
chacun dans son coin à dire stop à
l'apartheid ne faisait pas avancer les
choses en revanche en s'unissant en se
mettant ensemble en organisant des
manifestations
eh bien nous étions plus forts et on
faisait connaître sur ce régime raciste
insupportable c'est ça qui m'a poussé à
m'engager à adhérer au parti communiste
à la jeunesse communiste pour pouvoir
avec d'autres mener des combats et le
rendre visible ça m'a formé ce que
j'adore dans nelson mandela c'est pour
ça que pour moi c'est vraiment la
personnalité à retenir dans ce 20ème
siècle le siècle le passé ce que j'adore
chez lui c'est que il a été président de
la république ensuite après sa
libération et il a tout fait pour
construire une nation
à réconcilier
les noirs et les blancs ensemble pour
faire nation ensemble il n'a pas été
dans la vengeance
contre les blancs qui ont dirigé le pays
et qui ont été très durs et c'est cette
volonté de réconciliation qu'il
apportait avec monseigneur desmond
toutou qui est décédé récemment qui m'a
profondément marqué parce que c'était
pas gagné c'est très bien expliqué dans
le film invictus d'ailleurs et voilà
c'est ce que je retiens surtout de
nelson mandela que je veux retenir comme
le sont la réconciliation nationale
[Musique]